i mean you will see
the cars which now go into testing
within the next couple of weeks in plain
sight and for that reason then you see
it and you might have seen
uh first imagery of the cars obviously
carmo flashed in a nice way
but what you see is the real thing it's
not a prototype that car
later goes into serious production and
will be delivered to first clients end
of 2023
where's it going to sit in the
rolls-royce family i mean there's been a
lot of speculation it's going to take
the place of the dawn and the wraith
no this is a completely i would even
call it new segment within our range
that's also the reason why it carries
the name spectre
and doesn't use one of the existing
names and we have kept spectre exactly
for the reasons
to apply it to our first electric car
and it will fit nicely in the portfolio
in
and
it will be i would call it a new sort of
segment because it's fully electrified
uh but it is uh a true rolls-royce to
begin with and that's what our customers
asking for first it needs to be a proper
flawless peerless excellent rolls-royce
and then obviously it needs to be
electric and that's what we are doing
and we are looking obviously for quite a
lot of clients new clients clients we
haven't seen with the brand yet and
that's also the intention with spectre a
lot of car makers will tend to go for a
hybrid version of a vehicle before going
fully electric you're going all in all
electric why is that many reasons behind
it first of all many of our clients own
already electric cars
our clients are not let's say buying a
car to come from a to b when they buy a
rolls royce
so for that reason
range and whatever is not a serious
issue number two
we
thought that we are a fairly small
company and for that reason need to make
let's say smart
investment decisions for the future and
we think that the electric
route is definitely a safe haven also
long term and for that reason we decided
to go direct from combustion into
electric but even there's also still
some time to go with our marvelous
lovely 12 cylinder it will not phase out
tomorrow it will be step by step by step
until we are then by 2030 fully
electrified and i'm very very confident
that this is the right strategy for our
brand our customers and we have
talked to many of them
love electrification because it also
fits perfect to the brand it's silent
it's super talky it delivers what we
call waftability
we are not defining ourselves by loud
engines and noisy exhausts that's not
rolls-royce so for that reason i think
that's a good decision we have taken to
go direct from combustion into electric
but one thing maintains
also into the long long future and that
is that we are crafting our cars it is
hand built and will remain hand built
it takes over 800 hours until a rolls
royce goes live sort of
and that is the same also with spectre
and for that reason i think everything
is possible obviously bespoke whatever
you dream up as a as a customer is
possible with spectre as well a lot of
car manufacturers will take a loss on
their early electric vehicles i mean
your customers are a bit less price
resistant than uh some other car buyers
presumably you'll be looking to make
this a profitable model from the from
the start
definitely and ian allow me to say
shouldn't sound arrogant but if you ask
for the price you probably can't afford
it that's a famous rolls-royce say
and
it will maintain also with spectre rest
issued so but obviously we are
profitable